[Music]
this album is
ridiculously good you're just saying
that because no i'm not love me no no
wow
so
you know what song i can't get out of my
head
baby i'll wait such a good song thank
you i think that's the third single
and i've never had something that could
be a third single before
michael certainly has a lot to sing
about these days including his
relationship with his wife lusana i
thought my wife was the most beautiful
woman i'd ever seen in my life but i
didn't know her i was infatuated by her
and then we got married and even then
it was still pretty early i mean many
times i'm sure both of us looked at each
other and thought
you know
it was just the right thing
and then we had our first child and and
our second
and then when that thing happened with
noah
and we found out
who we had really married
i think that's when we fell in love
would you ever consider doing a duet
with lou maybe one day i don't i don't
know whatever i do with her i want it to
be organic meanwhile michael's big move
taking his show to vegas well i had
friends calling me saying oh you did it
you're doing a residency well i'm not
doing the celine they build a theater do
10 years i don't want to be in vegas for
10 years i want to be in vegas for four
shows a week for two weeks and then
travel to 50 countries all over the
world because that is my honor
[Music]